it like really surprised me in Japan
that you even have to like book out
shinkansen tickets like and if you don't
have the sometimes you know so the
shinkansen is like split up so that like
the first I think three cards are like
free so basically if you buy a ticket
for that day you can go on any scene
content that takes you to your
destination it's just if there's a seat
you can grab the seat if there's no seat
you have to stand up and the rest of it
is all yeah booked yeah that's all well
the Japan uh Japan uh rail passes all
those get those two so right we're kind
of competing against people who haven't
booked and also tourists right so it's
kind of tough because I think that on
some really busy routes you're really
very hard to get a chair yeah sometimes
last minute I've gotten those tickets
and like there's been a couple of
occasions where I've had to wait like a
station or two to just like wait for a
seat to open up so I'm just like
chilling I'm always I've always just
gone to the thing the uh machine yeah
and even because even if the Train's in
like five minutes I'll just still get
the reserve team yeah yeah because you
can just you can just get a ticket
really easily sometimes during busy
times of the year there's no yeah
can you get a ticket really easily I
don't know well there's there's one
there's one trip up about the shinkansen
that kind of [__] people a lot
um and it's it's not explained well at
all so you can buy The Limited fare
ticket yes which is like the first part
of the ticket yes but then if you want
to get a seat you have to buy another
ticket yeah for some reason they allow
you to buy the seat without buying the
limited fare ticket yeah I think it's
because of like the rail passes and
stuff yeah so you can ease very easily
accidentally buy the ticket seat think
that you have a ticket go to the gate
and then you won't be able to get
through yeah and then some guy will have
to awkwardly explain to you hey no you
got to go and buy this other ticket
you've only bought half the ticket yeah
I mean Japan Japan train system great
Japan train ticketing system it is the
booking anything in Japan it is the Dark
Souls boss of getting anywhere because I
have missed like especially now that you
know family and friends have come round
I I've now missed like at least at least
three Like Trains because
because of the ticketing system yeah we
arrive especially in a big group they
don't know obviously they don't know the
ticketing system and even me knowing the
ticketing system and knowing there's a
difference between like the limiting
Express and the limited one and
sometimes you can buy one and not the
other sometimes you just use suika and
not the other I'm going up there and I'm
like there are some times where I'm like
I am wasting at least 15 to 20 minutes
getting especially if that's like a big
group yeah you you are wasting at least
like 15 to 20 minutes with that you have
to like factor in and if you don't get
the tickets in time you just straight up
miss the [__] train yeah yeah that's
right if I go with a big group I just I
book it for everyone yeah I book it
online I get the tickets yeah I'll book
mine on the speaker because you can book
it to your circuit yeah you can pick on
them crazy convenient because you can
use that boop I'm in boys
no worries you can just tap in right
away yeah because sometimes I remember
when Sid's parents were here uh I booked
a train and it was a group of like at
the time it was like at least like seven
seven of us and getting a return ticket
for a trained do you know how many
[__] tickets that is yeah it's like
14 days
yeah you so so like I paid for it all at
once I got like 14 [__] tickets and
the receipts yeah right and we we we we
we had like 10 minutes being like okay
which one which one is the uh which
one's the one going out and which one's
return and whose is who and it doesn't
give you it in order either yeah so it
is it is a [__] nightmare getting
tickets in Japan well one thing I
learned about Japan and you maybe
correct me if I'm wrong on this there is
you do not save any money from buying a
return ticket not supposed to buying you
don't individually yeah unless it's like
you're coming back or going in a really
busy period where like you know because
like usually during like holidays it
goes up a little bit and like you know
depending on availability on the Train
sometimes like last minute tickets can
go up a little bit but like even then
it's like an extra [__] 10 20 bucks
yeah most I mean again I could be wrong
on that but from my so I always booked
the train going out and then coming back
I just I just rock up and I just buy the
ticket when I get there because it's
just like I don't want to deal with oh
no I'm my my shoot over ran oh I
finished early or whatever I'm just like
I'd rather just leave when I when I want
to leave yeah yeah exactly that's great
yeah I love the trains
trains are great as long as I don't have
to deal with the ticket machine if I
don't have to deal with the ticket
machine normally it's a very very good
experience I like the UK trains though
too I like the open return I do I great
you can just get a ticket open return
you take whatever [__] train you want
yeah and then you have one month the
moment you said that God like looked
over listen listen I I think the open
return is [__] sick it's a small
thing the one thing about it the one
thing about the shinkansen uh which you
have to appreciate is that it's ungodly
expensive yeah it is very expensive
sometimes it's more expensive than
taking a flight uh normally always yeah
normally always but that you have the
convenience of not having to travel all
the way to a [__] airport and go
through all that [__] yeah yeah with
like a one-way ticket to
uh Kyoto or Osaka is normally a hundred
bucks yeah at most and you know normally
you can get return flights for less than
that if you want to but I mean also you
should always hit the bullet train
there's better like you know if you're
going Beyond Osaka or Beyond not like
north of Japan you're pretty better off
flying yeah yeah like most [__] Chris
one time we're going to support her for
a video and Chris was hell-bent on
taking the train there and I was like
why are you why you want to take the
train he's like I just think it would be
much more enjoyable we can get more work
done and for some reason I let him
convince me into doing it I was like
let's just shut [__] [__] four and a
half hour train that was ungodly
expensive to hakudate and then we had to
wait around for an hour and then another
hour and a half training mind you guys
the shinkansen does not go to Sapporo
there's like a there's like a huge
distance between Supra and the last stop
yeah meanwhile the [__] flight we can
go to Canada our flight yeah it's like
it's like a 200 bucks each I believe
Chris kept managed to convince you I
can't believe he convinced me he was he
was pretty adamant about it and I was
like all right fine and then I did it
once now and I've I've constantly told
him that I've never done doing that ever
again yeah the only time that shinkansen
is worth it is if you're actually going
to talk without you how could that they
show because you can get like the one
thing I always tell people to experience
if they want to splurge a little bit uh
because it's by far the best route to do
it because the the the trains in Japan
they're run by two different companies
one that goes west towards uh um like
all soccer Kyoto one that goes and the
online goes north but they're not called
north and west it's the Jr sjr West but
but the shinkansen they use are
different uh in each area so they're
like I think uh Kyushu has one or two
shinkans that they're like their own
version there's not much difference
um but the the north one they have the
the grand class right which is like
really bougie and fancy you pay like an
extra hundred bucks but you get like
your own server on the train and drinks
and stuff so and like so basically
business class of Shane constant pretty
much so when when like uh Ludwig and and
uh some of the odd boys came I was like
yeah I should try it because we're going
to hug on that day yeah we may as well
try it we basically had the whole cart
to ourselves and you get the food and
the street and it was nice it was good I
just forgot my headphones so it's four
and a half hours of Silence
I can't believe I have to talk to my
friends no no no no they hold they all
had headphones
have fun in your silence solos yeah
you're gonna listen to it you did the
equivalent of forgetting to think bring
your phone when you're about to take a
[__]
what do I do now what do I do with my
life so I don't know that was it was
great but I I I you know if you you want
to splurge a bit of money you just get
it one way it's kind of it's a fun
experience to try and the chairs are
very nice have you ever been on any of
those like fancy trains in Japan like
dude you went on the sleeper train right
yeah I was a sleeper training that's not
[__] fancy [__] it's a bed it's [__]
it's not worth it what was better the
tour bus or the sleeping train tour bus
100 oh are you serious no no no no doubt
probably you have to bear in mind like
the the sleeper train the worst part
about the sleeper train is that
um at least the one I got you I could
have chose a better route but there was
it was first of all impossible to book
yeah impossible I it I you you cannot
fathom how [__] this website is this is
the single shittest website I've ever
seen in my life it does not work flat
out and then
I had to get two Japanese people to help
me figure out this goddamn website and
it took but all three of us [__]
around on this website trying different
inputs to get this thing to work because
if you put one wrong input you'd go all
the way back you can't press the back
button you have to restart all the
inputs type the station you could you
have to say the exact time you want so
you can't look at all the trains you
have to put a time in and if there's not
a train at that time nothing will show
up it won't say hey by the way in two
hours another train which is insanitive
it's insane so you just have to know
what time the train is yeah and then on
top of that
um it's it's all booked out constantly
because trying to attackers in Japan run
it they run the show you don't have a
chance yeah competing against them sure
um and then so it will tell you like hey
there's free carts in this train on this
website and you click it and then you
open it and it'll say there's no cards
and you're like what and it'll be like
luxury normal standard and they'll say
like all sold out but then you click on
like the X where it says it's all sold
out and you open a drop down menu and be
like Oh but there is two and it's like
psychotic
[Music]
with like that X knowing I had to go
through all that just to get on the
train yeah and then you get on the train
and we got on at like 11 p.m and then at
5am or 6 a.m I started blasting the
announcements of all the stations yeah
and so it's kind of hard to get any
sleep and you know you've got to get off
the train at like eight yeah so you're
on this train at 11. ideally you're not
shooting a video like we were and you're
in bed right away
um but even then it's small it's crap
it's kind of hot and stuffy right I wish
the bus was way better that was air
conditioned I will say the one the one
really really cool thing about the super
train and it is the best part about it
is that like just lying down and like
waking up and then having this awesome
window you can just watch through it is
really cool for like two hours of Sun
like you get yeah I I can understand why
there is kind of like a train culture in
Japan like not not just like you know
train culture I'll take my coffee by the
way okay we'll take we'll take the
coffees Now give me my desserts they
arrived and uh I just wanted to [__]
around and find out uh I would smoke one
right yeah don't worry guys they're cold
they're not gonna have fun this is this
doesn't count I just wanna this doesn't
count towards one of the coffees I'm
drinking even though it definitely is a
coffee but not like I I've only had like
I would say a I wouldn't call it like a
positive train experience but like I
kind of like uh aha moment where train
rides can be really like kind of like a
really cool experience and the only time
I've had that is in Japan
um because to me like trains have always
been kind of like cars they're like a
tool to get me from point A to point
also I mean going from Brighton to
London was one of the somehow shittest
Journeys oh it's [__] [__] so I think
that also doesn't help the fact that you
had to always do that yeah that was a
terrible Journey yeah yeah but uh you
know uh me and Cindy had a little bit of
like a vacation in like the Izu
prefecture recently and to get to the
easy prefecture yeah we use the train
and the train goes all around the
coastline of like of like Southern Japan
and it is the most beautiful train ride
I've liked is that the romance car that
is not the romance car goes to uh
yeah the romance she's got loads of that
too yeah so all the trains go around the
app on the outskirts yeah and like it
happens to be like a [__] beautiful
day in the in the summer not the summer
in the spring before it was like too
[__] hot uh and you just saw like the
mountains and the seaside and I'm like
holy [__] this is so [__] beautiful
and I get to experience this just like
going from point A to point B you know
I'm like uh and then it was on this it
was on this train ride that we saw like
we saw the we saw this [__]
hogwarts-ass looking train on this like
on the train track go past us and we're
like what the [__] is that I've got what
it's called but there is like a specific
trade an SL sorry an SL what's an SL uh
this uh [__] steam line or something
like it's it's the steam trains right
there's a few luxury
yeah it's it's kind of like one of these
like luxury trains it looks like it's
like come straight out of Hogwarts uh it
doesn't look like any of like the modern
trains that you see yeah uh and we just
saw like a bunch of people just having a
meal and just it's kind of like those
old like railway trains you see in like
the like early America yeah yeah where
you know old like oil tycoon type type
people just sit down and just like be
served at high class meal and stuff
oh but uh yeah I didn't know those
Services exist in Japan and uh we looked
into it and there are a lot yeah there's
a ton there's one in Hokkaido that Chris
went on on journey across Japan and it
was like it was just one train that runs
for that day across like the central
Hokkaido and the seats are [__]
impossible to get yeah from the outside
it's straight up just looks like a
Hogwarts train yeah like people always
like oh man I want to go and go on this
train I'm like good luck you you can't
compete against these trainer talkers
they they again like I said they run it
yeah they run it they know more than you
they care more than you they they're on
the website they know exactly when it's
going up you you are not out competing
these guys Lord knows I've goddamn tried
um I've been trying to get tickets to go
on the Kyushu one for ages uh and I just
not only is that website again terrible
and impossible to navigate maybe that's
the barrier you know it is but like I I
got a I got a friend to call them up and
they were like yeah we will uh we will
release information about tickets soon
didn't say when didn't say [__] of
course the train attackers know when
it's going up somehow they always know
because they've got like a they got like
friends and they're telling each other
yeah
yeah it's like the Inner Circle yeah
yeah I'm like I can't hey it's unfair
let me write the goddamn train I want to
go on the Seven Stars and Kyushu but
you're not a trainer talking I'm not
you're not you're not fit for it dude I
realize that like that built death
because presumably you know the sleeper
train there's there's like multiple
every day and we were at one at like 11
50 p.m and it was like the paparazzi
came out to watch these two trains dock
yeah yeah it's crazy there was like 40
people with dslrs going like
they're watching these two trains just
like Doc like like this and then
everyone's like oh
a couple of them definitely nodded when
they saw it yeah
this was this was dojin to them you know
but I don't need porn
I remember watching a YouTube video and
praying about this I think it was Seven
Stars and Q shoes around there's just a
guy who had like he made his own fan
club for the train for [__] sake what
the mozzie bite me on the lip yeah yeah
for [__]
I've been scratching it and I'm like why
is the bump disappeared on my lip I
don't think it was there at the
beginning of this episode we can check
that I think it's just been forming I
haven't done those yet yeah that's gonna
be there the whole episode this guy had
made a one-person fan club for like this
train what one person oh I think he
would rock up to every time the train
would leave yeah
I just had a rubber band that flew
somewhere around it's right there
he made it so he would turn up every
single time the train departed with like
a banner and stuff and be there and I'm
like okay like train fan club and I'm
like man that's I wish I got that much
joy from just seeing a train
I wish I'm always so fast I'm so jealous
of them yeah